And the answer here may be surprisingly is that using this random assignment here
we will on average already get half of the variables right
and that is of course because we have a 50% chance for each single variable
of actually getting it right when we do it by coin flip
because if in a satisfying assignment this variable needs to be set to false,
there's a 50% chance that a random assignment will also set it to false
and if it needs to be set to true, there is also 50% chance that we actually set it to true
using this randomized assignment.
Now, of course, sometimes we might get more variables correct and sometimes less
but especially if N is large we can expect to get about half of the variables right in an average run.
Now, the success-factor II, once we are half way there so to say
what are the chances that using this process here will get us through the satisfying assignment
again, if the original Boolean formula actually has one of those.